today we're checking out the new Solana
Saga mobile phone which is one of the
first wet three Focus mobile devices
built on the Solana blockchain now even
though we are very much still at a
crypto and iot bear Market even if
you're not a fan of web 3 nfts or even
any crypto in general I think this phone
is a very interesting play to see how
blockchain Tech can be built into Mobile
especially with Solana creating their
own platform for devs called the Solana
mobile stack but first before we get
into it let's unbox it and check it out
so here it is
are you ready for the peel
[__] almost dropped it so we have the
Solana logo we also have a fingerprint
sensor on the back we have two cameras
here on the rear and we have one camera
here on the front I like the little
green buttons here actually it's more
like a teal color
looks nice it's a great accent see what
else is in the Box we've got a SIM card
ejector oh we have a seed freeze card
very important this is our recovery
sheet so before we get into what makes
this phone different let's go over some
of the normal things that we usually
cover when we're reviewing phones it has
a 50 megapixel made a 12 megapixel Ultra
wide camera and a 16 megapixel selfie
camera the display is a 16.67 full HD
Plus AMOLED with a peak refresh rate of
120 hertz it's got a rear fingerprint
sensor dual SIM 12 gigs of RAM 512 gigs
of storage it's running a Snapdragon 8
plus gen 1 processor and it has a 4011
milliamp battery and it looks like I
have already smudged it up so on the
first inspection
um I've already fingerprinted it up but
I love the material like this feels like
a premium fall like just the weight of
it in my hand I sometimes don't really
like light phones because I feel like
I'm not holding anything it's it's also
not too slippery even like the new
Samsung s23 and the iPhone feels so
slippery like this I mean it'll
definitely slip out of my hands but it
doesn't feel as slippery as some of the
newer phones I do also like that it has
the fingerprint sensor here on the back
it's like a perfect placement for if
you're trying to unlock your phone let's
turn it on oh look it looks solota logo
this is exciting at our fingerprints
foreign
there we are fingerprint hasn't added
seed Vault secure seed storage at your
fingertips we're gonna create a new seed
we can't let you see it we're gonna
protect our seed with a passcode seed
passcode let me go write this down
so I've written down my seed phrase I've
hit it away and I need to enable
fingerprint abscess to the seed in my C
Vault so we're gonna enable and here we
go okay
with seed as we created and secured in
order to use your seed pair it with a
wallet as well okay all right I use the
Phantom wallet it's a thing that I also
like is this has a the app store which
is an entire App Store dedicated to
decentralized apps and since this still
is early there's not a lot Allah
claim our Saga and Jenna Okay saw the
genus oh my goodness all right
connectable hair so many things are
happening right now I typed in my 24
word seed phrase again get started so
here's the D app store and it's asking
to authenticate
and we're in it's easy we've got this is
a brand new account I don't have any
Solana or anything yet
foreign
it's all set up definitely excited to
test this out further now one of the
problems that I've run into and if you
are also into nfts or crypto is how
difficult and not secure things are to
transact on mobile now most of the time
you do need a desktop or you need to
have a wallet app browser and it's super
frustrating to try to navigate and it's
also not entirely secure now I mostly
use a cold storage Hardware wallet for a
lot of my larger transactions which adds
another entire layer of complication to
things especially if I don't have my
ledger with me now what I do like about
the Saga is that they are introducing a
seed Vault so your salon of private keys
and seeds are stored securely protected
by a dedicated Hardware security module
call it a secure element now when you're
using any decentralized apps their
Mobile Wallet adapter can be used for
signing transactions keys and seeds are
only used to sign transactions so your
keys are never actually shared with
Solana apps or Android to keep you safe
now I did show you guys the d-app store
where you'll have access to hopefully a
growing number of decentralized apps in
the future as you can see right now it's
pretty slim so now this is running on
the Solana blockchain and I still feel
like there's a lot of questions that a
lot of people have if you're not
familiar with this or you have been
following it so blockchain Tech is a way
of storing and transferring data that is
secure transparent and decentralized now
because the blockchain creates a
permanent record of transactions they
can't be deleted or altered so this
reduces the risk of fraud now this isn't
to say that there aren't a ton of nft
scams out there because there are tons
of them there's lots of crypto scams but
a lot of that does not have anything to
do with the blockchain technology
specifically that's just because people
are very crafty and know how to scam
their way in and out of your wallets I
like this because you actually own your
assets and you could transfer or sell
them if you want I kind of think of this
when I was playing Animal Crossing but
my entire Island that I've spent 1700
hours playing and building if that was
something that was on the blockchain I
would be able to easily transfer that
entire Island to someone else or all of
those items that I have inside of my
Island I could actually be selling those
to you or to whoever wants them and each
one of those assets wouldn't just be
something that I would have in the game
it would be something that I physically
well digitally owned and would be able
to do whatever I wanted with them now if
there was some other game that was on
that particular blockchain that also
decided to share those same assets I
could then take those assets into I
don't know for example if it's Call of
Duty I get baby takes off my wardrobe
the outfits that I had made or created
in Animal Crossing or purchased and I
could wear them in Call of Duty like a
lot of this yes it can be done using
other Tech not on the blockchain and it
has been done as we've all seen in a way
more centralized way there's a lot of
pros and cons to both but we are getting
so way off topic of the Solana phone
that I don't even know where this video
is going so while I think that this is
very interesting and as a very long time
holder of Solana I really really hope
that it continues to Prevail and I hope
that my my bags will get pumped because
I had bought Solana super early when it
was very very low but then I also bought
it at an all-time high so it definitely
Cuts pretty deep when I look at the
current charts of where Solana is now
will the FTX crash has ultimately hurt
the entire financial industry in so many
ways especially Solana since it was
alameda's second largest holding at this
point I am just going to continue to
hold so I'm going to be either going up
with this ship or I'm gonna be going
down with it I even originally had plans
to launch my own project on Solana
because the appeal originally was the
low transaction fees and it being a much
more environmentally chained than if 1.0
at the time but then the entire crypto
crash happens and then I ended up never
doing anything with it it's called jpeg
you guys can follow along if you want to
I have the Instagram jpeg form and I
also have the Twitter jpeg I definitely
do still have plans to launch it I
probably was working on it for about
four months just drawing and
illustrating so one of these days I do
plan on jpeg it's just a fun passion
project and I think it was one of those
things that I wanted to learn how to
make generative art so I taught myself
procreate figured out how to actually
merge all of the layers and Export those
into a final project to be able to
generate a 10 000 Pig project where
everyone is so different it was really
fun and the reason that I was so into
Solana is like I said there are low
transaction fees a lot of ethereum
projects like you're paying so much in
gas fees that you were just wasting
money at the end of the day so even if
you hate nfts or you hate crypto that's
totally fine but I did just kind of want
to show you this phone I'm just going to
give you a first look at something
different that's out there so having a
device like this that is web 3 and
crypto focused I think is really
interesting now is this a great time to
be launching a crypto Solana phone I I
don't know about that but the fact that
it is out and it is something that is
here I will be interested to see what
developers are currently working on with
this so anyway I just wanted to give you
guys a first look at the Solana phone it
will be out very shortly and this was
announced well way before the crypto
crash so I do feel like had this been
released a little bit earlier I think
that more people would have definitely
been into it so I'm very excited though
to see kind of what people think like is
this something that you would purchase
it is a pretty high price point this is
about a thousand dollar phone but I do
think this is something that is kind of
early I don't think it's going to be
widely adopted right now we're still
struggling to get people to set up any
type of decentralized wallet so the fact
that there's a phone dedicated to that I
mean that's gonna be a whole other step
we're not ready for this I mean I'm
ready for it I don't think the general
public is ready for it but I would love
to hear what you guys think so feel free
to leave me some comments below and let
me know what you think of the Solana
Saga or even a crypto web threefold in
general thank you guys for watching if
you have any other questions feel free
to leave me some questions in the
comments or feel free to send me some
tweets on Twitter and I will try to
answer them for you